على بعد حوالي 44 ميلاً من مركز الزلزال
ولكن الضرر واضح هنا في
مراكش، سأخرج من
الإطار للحظة، يمكنك أن ترى خلفي،
هذا أحد المباني هنا في المدينة
المنورة في البلدة القديمة والذي تم
الحفاظ عليه  الأضرار الناجمة عن
زلزال ليلة الجمعة وهناك جيوب
من هذه المدينة ذات الكثافة
السكانية العالية والتي تعرضت لأضرار
نتيجة للزلزال ولكن بالطبع
هذا لا شيء مقارنة
بالدمار الهائل الذي نشهده في
المنطقة المحيطة  منطقة مركز الزلزال عبر
سفوح جبال الأطلس،
وهناك بالطبع رأينا بعض
القرى التي سويت بالأرض بالكامل
نتيجة لهذا الزلزال، وهذا مؤكد أن
جهود الإنقاذ لا تزال
مستمرة إلى حد كبير الآن بالطبع
هناك قلق حولها
يوجد ضغط كبير على
فرق الإنقاذ في التوقيت هنا، وخلال اليومين الماضيين
كان من الصعب جدًا الوصول إلى
بعض هذه القرى في اتجاه
الحلقة، وهي مناطق نائية في
الجبل وقد تضررت بعض الطرق.
نتيجة للزلزال،
فقد تسبب في بعض التأخير في
وصول فرق الإنقاذ إلى هناك، وقد
شاهدنا مقاطع فيديو سمعناها من
شهود عيان يصفون أنفسهم وهم
يبحثون عن أحبائهم تحت
الأنقاض بأيديهم العارية،
لكننا بالطبع نفعل ذلك  أعلم أن
الحكومة المغربية تتولى زمام المبادرة
في عمليات البحث والإنقاذ الجوية
للجيش المسؤول بالطبع عن هذه
العملية هنا في مراكش، ويبدو الأمر كما
لو أن الناس بدأوا في العودة إلى
بعض الإحساس بالحياة الطبيعية، حيث
يواصل الناس حياتهم ولكن
بالطبع لا يزال هناك شعور
بالخوف الحقيقي هنا ذكرت أن هناك أشخاصًا
ينامون في الخارج أثناء الليل وفي
ليلة أخرى رأينا عائلات متجمعة
معًا في الشوارع، كثير منهم
خائفون من أن منازلهم ليست
آمنة، وقد تضررت المباني في
تلك البداية  زلزال أو أنهم
يخشون احتمال حدوث
هزة ارتدادية قوية رأينا هزات ارتدادية
اليوم والتي لن يؤدي إلا إلى
زيادة هذا الشعور بالتخوف